[Música]
bienvenidos a este avance informativo en
france 24 estamos por el momento
llevando les una programación de
noticias más corta de lo habitual esto
debido a las medidas de seguridad en
medio de un crítico momento de la
pandemia en colombia en cuya capital
bogotá se encuentran en nuestros
estudios iniciamos en brásil el gobierno
de este país confirmó la celebración de
la copa américa en su territorio después
de que se descartara en argentina y
colombia como sedes del certamen
el presidente de jair bolsonaro se ha
mostrado partidario de acoger el torneo
a pesar del preocupante avance de la
pandemia que ya deja más de 462 mil
muertos en el país lo que deja al
gigante suramericano sólo por detrás de
eeuu en número de fallecidos los
partidos comenzarían el 13 de junio y se
jugarán sin públicos según confirmó el
ministro de la presidencia luís ramos
confirmada la copa américa en brasil
venció la coherencia la bandera de
brasil que alberga los partidos de la
libertadores sudamericana sin hablar de
los campeonatos regionales y brasileños
no podría dar la espalda a un campeonato
tradicional como éste
vamos a chile en donde el presidente
sebastián piñera pronunció su discurso
anual ante el congreso rindiendo cuentas
en su último año de gobierno el
conservador se mostró partidario de
aprobar el matrimonio igualitario
anunció que otorgará mensaje de urgencia
a un proyecto de ley al respecto que
está estancado desde el 2017 en el
legislativo también reconoció que se
cometieron abusos y atropellos durante
el estallido social de 2019
nuestra corresponsal patricia luna nos
cuenta más desde santiago
ha llegado el momento del matrimonio
igualitario en nuestro país con estas
palabras sorprendía al presidente
sebastián piñera tanto a su bancada como
la posición al anunciar que el proyecto
de matrimonio igualitario que en chile-
lleva años dormido en el congreso será
retomado con carácter de suma urgencia
esto fue muy destacado por algunos
sectores de la oposición para algunos
fue la única cosa positiva de este
último discurso en el que el presidente
sebastián piñera también pidió perdón a
las personas a las que las ayudas
sociales por la pandemia llegaron de
forma tardía y anunció la creación de
una unidad especializada en derechos
humanos dentro de la fiscalía que estará
a cargo de investigar y poder sancionar
de la manera adecuada las violaciones a
los derechos humanos ocurridas durante
el estallido social de octubre de 2019 y
en los meses posteriores el presidente
también anunció que se incrementará la
financiación del instituto nacional de
derechos humanos que jugó un rol
fundamental en perseguir y denunciar
estas violaciones a los derechos humanos
son las líneas más destacadas de la
última cuenta pública de sebastián
piñera que se realizó este martes desde
valparaíso y en el que repasó
han sido los hitos de su mandato y
también anunció cuáles serán sus
prioridades para lo que le queda por
delante apenas diez meses de gobierno de
su último segundo mandato
y en estados unidos joe biden se
convirtió hoy en el primer presidente en
visitar el lugar de la masacre de tulsa
en oklahoma a propósito de los 100 años
de uno de los peores capítulos en la
historia de violencia racial del país
entre el 31 de mayo y el primero de
junio de 1921 una turba racista atacó
los hogares de un barrio afroamericano
dejando al menos 300 personas fallecidas
el mandatario reafirmó su compromiso de
acabar con el racismo sistémico en el
país y anunció medidas destinadas a
cerrar la brecha económica que afecta
mayoritariamente a los afroamericanos
sobre todo en materia de vivienda
llegamos al final de este avance
informativo ustedes quédense con
nosotros pueden consultar esta y otras
informaciones en france 24 puntos